you know how much canada loved you and
how excited we
are for this nomination how are you
so great
oh so good listen there has been so much
fanfare all over the world especially
here in canada
for your show but there has to be for
each of you
someone who you found out was a fan and
you were shocked or excited
so who was that person for each of you
when you found out they were fans of the
show
or they watched the show you got that
feeling in your belly or
it just made you feel away
i i think i mean there were there were
so many of those markers
along the way that you're like what what
um i think one of the biggest
which you know for me and i know daniel
obviously being you know a huge mariah
carey fan
me being a huge maya carrick fan myself
when he texts
me saying that she had tweet
tweeted about it i can't remember what
the text was that was like to me
when mariah carey is tweeting about your
job
i think it's it that that was definitely
um that was definitely that moment for
me
i'm trying to think i remember watching
the panel i think it was with
the rose family and ted danson
was on that channel and said something
to
everyone in the show about what a fanny
was and i thought that was like
he's such a comedy icon and i just
thought wow
that's so cool he gushed over annie on
one of their things and everyone was
like
wow somebody actually just told me today
uh jen and sarah kerry just told me
today that would take the bridgeton cast
because of course you know i mean i got
binge to that show like the rest of the
world so
to find out that they know who we are
so we still it's all it's that moment
it's like they know
who they are yeah still and all the
ladies that i met last week at the lcbo
at the
uh yes of course of course
ladies at the lcbo i'm with you i get
that yes
what did you steal from set as a little
memento to keep
could we see those items in a movie
because the fans are still crying for a
movie now that the show is done
well if i lean just this way you can see
a bird there
and that is from when david redid the
blouse barn
oh i've got one right in the shot there
what a strange thing to take
here oh god
perfect kevin what about you
what did you guys say um i took
i took one of the um protest signs
from uh from that demonstration that
happened outside
city hall when moira um when moira said
moira said some um unsavory things about
shit's creek
um and i think my sign says we're really
disappointed
i think that's the one that i took oh
and i also stole him
i'm sorry that was one of my favorite
signs too
oh my god i love that i also love the
one that said
say you're sorry that was fantastic
so canadian useful
i took um i really just took some
cafe items i took a menu of course i
kept my name tag
and i took a
part of the chalkboard that's from the
diner that was
up on the wall that says the drinks on
it
and it's just leaning in my in my
house and i i
i see it every day and it's it's i look
at it quite fondly it's so
such a nice little memory to have
amazing sounds like if a movie happens
you're in
well i think we're all in i think if we
if we bribe daniel enough if we like
give him
whatever that is pizza or likes a trip
i think we might we might eat something
out of him
even an idea but i think we'd all be i
think literally everybody would be on
board for it
it's absolutely right